bố binh nhà chương của người giáo dục.
Mối mối chương là một không ra anh ăn toàn,
giết văn của các bạn phúc không chỉ dạy chữ,
mà dạy làm người bối đáp nhìn tác,
chỉ loạt tòng đến anh,
và chắc nghĩ công dân,
kịp thời gian dạy.
Nên lợi như học sinh khó khăn,
bị tổn thương, bị cô lập,
có mùi cơ, bỏ học,
tựt đối không để bỏ lực suốt phạy,
kỳ thịt, cách nạn trong trường họng.
Lụ với ra đình,
mối ông mà chàng mẹ,
bố nghĩ chăm sóc chám,
hãy là điểm tựa thân yêu đầu tiên của các cháu,
cháam cần được hắn ngàn,
tôn chào,
bốn dẫn và mạo vẻ.
Kỳ lạc không đồng nghiệm bỏ lực,
giải con không thể bận trự mang hay bỏ mặt.
Bố ra đình là lời để cháam được lưới lên trong bình thương,
sự chăm sóc,
hình tin và chắc dạy.
Bỏ lạc,